el 25 de octubre del año 1906 santiago
ramón y cajal recibió el premio nobel
por lo que él llamó la doctrina de la
neurona básicamente él definía que
nuestro cerebro estaba formado por una
serie de células llamadas neuronas que
se comunicaban entre sí más de un siglo
después sabemos que nuestro cerebro hay
unos 86 mil millones de estas células 86
mil millones de estas neuronas que se
comunican entre sí a través de la
sinapsis y son las que albergan nuestros
recuerdos nuestros anhelos nuestras
memorias
se estima que una sola neurona puede
llegar a tener 10.000 conexiones
diferentes con otras neuronas diferentes
formando parte de miles de circuitos
esto genera que nuestro cerebro la cifra
total de conexiones y de contactos entre
neuronas sea de 860 billones más o menos
tampoco podemos saberlo a ciencia cierta
esto lo sé lo comento para que tengan en
cuenta lo complicado que es investigar
cómo funciona nuestro nuestro cerebro
para entenderlo de una forma un poco más
sencilla voy a utilizar una analogía
entendamos una neurona como si fuera una
palabra en este caso como la palabra
cerebro esta palabra puede asociarse con
otras palabras diferentes se van
comunicando unas con otras para formar
una frase y esta frase tiene un sentido
tiene un significado esta misma palabra
cerebro se puede asociar con otras
palabras diferentes para obtener otra
frase el sentido cambia pero la palabra
sigue siendo la misma
lo mismo pasa con otra frase diferente
en total pensad que podrían ser 10.000
frases diferentes pues esto lo ocurre
con nuestras sinapsis en el cerebro
estas neuronas pueden llegar a formar
parte de 10.000 circuitos diferentes
aunque la neurona sea la misma
además de esta complicación debemos
sumarle que nuestro cerebro junto con
todos estos miles de millones de
neuronas
hay otros 85 mil millones más o menos de
otros tipos celulares vale esto en esta
imagen que tenéis del laboratorio pues
se ven en rosita los astrocitos que son
otro tipo de celular - en el cerebro
todo esto se lo estoy contando hoy para
que tengan en cuenta lo difícil lo
complicado que es de saber cómo funciona
el cerebro porque no lo sabemos y lo
complicado que es mucho más si se trata
de cerebro patológico de tele o enfermo
estamos en una situación en la que nos
enfrentamos a enfermedades cuyo origen
por norma general desconocemos
otro problema además de todos estos
números incalculables que les he dicho
es que no tenemos la tecnología
suficiente ni los neurocientíficos y los
neurólogos para enfrentarse a estas
enfermedades para ver qué ocurre en
estas enfermedades
rafael yuste uno de los neurocientíficos
más importantes del mundo que es español
pero es investiga en eeuu personalmente
siempre pone un ejemplo un ejemplo que
yo cree que es muy claro cuando miramos
el cerebro ya sea un cerebro sano o un
cerebro enfermo es como si me hacemos a
una pantalla de esta pantalla como la
que tenemos aquí solo con la tecnología
actual solo podemos ver un píxel de la
pantalla solo podemos ver ese partido
punto azul que ven ahí podemos hacerlo
más grande podemos estudiarlo desde
muchos puntos de vista pero es lo único
que podemos ver esto hace que cuando
miramos el cerebro no estamos viendo la
imagen completa no sabemos qué es lo que
está ocurriendo de verdad en una
enfermedad cómo nos puede evocar este
cuadro de salvador dalí la persistencia
de la memoria cuando miramos un cerebro
con alzheimer no vemos la imagen
completa
pero todo este mensaje pesimista que le
estoy contando que parece yo quiero
cambiar por completo esa forma de pensar
vale yo hoy estoy aquí para contarles
una hipótesis que tengo una una
hipótesis sobre una revolución sobre una
revolución en la neurociencia en la
forma de entender el mundo que va a ser
de estas revoluciones que se estudian en
los libros de texto en el futuro o en lo
que se en los hologramas sobre lo que se
utilice para estudiar los próximos años
una revolución que va a cambiar nuestra
forma de ver el mundo y de entendernos a
nosotros mismos una revolución que
podríamos llamarlo la revolución así
flipando un poco de la neurociencia
ficción porque porque están ocurriendo
cosas ahora mismo en los laboratorios
que antes sólo pertenecían a los libros
y película de cine ficción esta
revolución que yo defiendo se basa en
tres pilares fundamentales y voy a dar
un poquito de ellos el primero de ellos
es inversión como no en ciencia
evidentemente necesitamos el dinero pero
no inversión es una inversión muy
particular y es que los principales las
principales potencias del mundo las
principales potencias económicas se han
dado cuenta que hay que invertir en
saber cómo funciona el cerebro luego ya
lo curaremos
a ver qué pasa eeuu tiene the brain
initiative que es uno de los proyectos
más grandes a nivel económico que se han
hecho en la historia de la humanidad
cuyo cabeza por cierto visible es rafael
yuste en europa tenemos the human brain
project otro proyecto que es simplemente
para saber cómo funciona el cerebro para
curar en zona de repito
en japón existe un proyecto sean brain
mind korea por ejemplo tiene su proyecto
del cerebro humano también o proyectos
como el del instituto al de eeuu que son
proyectos filantrópicos que también
investigan lo mismo como digo estos son
proyectos de unas cuantías económicas
inmensas y que buscan saber qué está
pasando en el cerebro vale cómo funciona
y podrán decir aquí no están todas las
potencias del mundo no nos faltan
algunas porque no está europa está eeuu
está japón korea también pues es que
precisamente hace 89 días fina se ha
sumado este barco sin ha decidido hacer
una inversión multimillonaria para saber
cómo funciona el cerebro simplemente
cómo funciona algo tan básico como es
todos estos proyectos los que están
activos por el chino te han empezado
suponen más o menos unos 600 millones de
euros de inversión al año cada año 600
millones 600 millones de euros podemos
decir qué barbaridad cuantísimos dinero
no pues depende de con qué lo comparemos
si lo comparamos con el muro de donald
trump
ahora mismo valorado según lo quería
ayer en 21 mil 600 millones de dólares
construir un muro vale y el ejemplo del
muro se lo he traído para que entienda
una cosa muy importante en estos
proyectos de investigación investigan
personas independientemente de su lugar
de origen de su religión obviamente de
su condición sexual da igual porque la
ciencia lo que busca es romper fronteras
la ciencia lo que hace es tender puentes
valioso que tenemos que tener muy claro
y de hecho una frase que siempre me
gusta repetir insistir es que la única
frontera en la que el ser humano debe de
invertir es en la frontera del
conocimiento vale y esto lo que lo que
hace la ciencia así es el poder
transformador que tiene
de frontera el conocimiento es lo que va
el segundo pilar de esta hipótesis que
hoy les estoy contando y es que yo le
llamaba la interdisciplinaridad he
querido elegir una palabra fácil para
decir una charla tez entonces
interdisciplinaridad al odio otra vez es
que haga falta aquí me refiero con eso a
que la forma de trabajar en los
laboratorios ha cambiado antes estaban
los biólogos celulares bioquímicos
biólogos moleculares etcétera ahora en
un laboratorio de neurociencia te puedes
encontrar al neurocientífico al
neurólogo pero también al físico al
matemático al ingeniero al informático
incluso al filósofo al artista esto está
generando que estén pasando unas cosas
alucinantes a cosas que ya os digo que
son de ciencia ficción pura y dura por
ejemplo los interfaces cerebro-ordenador
todas estas letras que tienen aquí
simplemente es para acompañarme lo que
voy a decir a continuación se está
consiguiendo gracias a ordenadores
suplir funciones que nuestro cerebro ha
perdido ya sea por accidente o por
enfermedad aquí me refiero con esto me
refiero a personas que ante una
amputación en un accidente se le les
pongas neuroprótesis que pueden mover
con su cerebro eso es muy fácil
pero es que ya pueden llegar a sentir lo
que están tocando a sentir calor en
estos dedos biónicos vale estoy hablando
de investigaciones como alguna de las
querían aquí que han conseguido que
personas tetrapléjicas puedan mover un
brazo robótico y volver a comer de un
brazo que están moviendo con su cerebro
vale pero es que es más el año pasado
ese mismo grupo de investigación
consiguió que una persona tetrapléjica
pueda volver a mover sus propios brazos
todo todo eso es con un sistema
informático que vuelve a conectar lo que
está desconectado vale estamos hablando
de investigación que ya les digo que
parece de frank stein o algo así pero es
totalmente real de hecho uno de los
artículos desde que me dedico a la
investigación el más bonito yo creo que
he leído es este que tiene aquí es de la
revista 'new england journal of
medicine' la mejor revista del mundo sea
la más importante del mundo en ciencia
es esta revista en ella presentan el
caso de una paciente que se llama gene
que de bruijn que tiene esclerosis
lateral amiotrófica está tras la famosa
enfermedad que padecía stephen hawking y
muchísima otra gente que es una
enfermedad que afecta a tus motoneuronas
y lo que hace es que vas perdiendo la
movilidad de los músculos pero tu
cerebro está
esta mujer llegaba a llevar un punto
está en un punto de la enfermedad la que
no podía comunicarse con el medio
exterior o lo tenía muy difícil gracias
a un interfaz cerebro ordenador
consiguieron conectando un sistema a su
cerebro cuando ya utiliza un pensamiento
muy arraigado un pensamiento que está
muy muy muy básico en su cerebro como
era abrir y cerrar una mano podía
desplazar un curso sobre un teclado en
una pantalla sólo con sus cerebros a con
con su cero pudo mover el teclado y
volver a comunicarse el potencial que
tiene estas investigaciones es realmente
es brutal a mí me fascina y de hecho por
ejemplo en esto está invirtiendo
muchísimo y no facebook por ejemplo
porque yo les interesa que podamos
escribir directamente con la mente y
esto es ciencia real y el último punto
de esta hipótesis que yo diciendo que
está cambiando la forma de entender el
cerebro es el factor humano es la gente
o sea eso es lo más importante aquí
utilizando adaptando una frase muy
mítica de eduardo galeano que dice yo
nada está bien puesto así como muchos
científicos pequeños en lugares pequeños
haciendo cosas pequeñas son los que
están cambiando el mundo aquí yo
añadiría muchos sentidos pequeños en
lugares pequeños con financiación a
veces
ridícula son los que están cambiando el
mundo a qué me refiero vivimos en una
época de estrés de humanidad en el que
hay es la vez de la historia de la
ciencia que más personas están
investigando el cerebro todas estas
cosas que os he contado que están en
laboratorios gigantes o en laboratorios
pequeñitos como el que tenemos en ciudad
real donde se investiga alzhéimer se
investiga parkinson se investiga tumor
cerebral estamos hablando de núcleos de
investigación que están surgiendo por
toda áfrica por todo el sudeste asiático
por toda latinoamérica en todo el mundo
hay gente investigando y lo más bonito
de todo esto es que el conocimiento que
generamos es global es compartido o sea
nosotros publicamos nuestros resultados
y puede venir otra persona después
cogerlos y seguir investigando eso y eso
es fantástico y esto además la comunidad
científica no se mueve a contar una cosa
muy importante y es que debemos de
estamos casi obligados a salir a la
calle y a contar lo que hacemos y a
contar lo que es la ciencia aquí tienen
un par de imágenes de algunas
actividades que hacemos en ciudad real
porque porque nosotros somos unos nos
encanta lo que hacemos pero tenemos que
convencer a la gente de que la ciencia
de la ciencia sencilla de que la ciencia
es asequible porque es la forma de
comenzar a nuestros políticos para que
inviertan en ella yo siempre hablo de
una hipótesis o como queráis llamarlo
que lo llama como la hipótesis de la
charla nosotros los investigadores pues
más o menos hacemos una llevamos una
carrera que es clásica no te sacas con
licenciatura sacas un máster de lo de
verdad le sacas un doctorado y empiezas
a investigar más o menos puedes estar
investigando pues 40 años más si 40 45
depende de cómo vaya la cosa de bien
a lo largo de los años pasa a generar
conocimiento caso global pero el impacto
que puede tener la sociedad es muchísimo
mayor si dedicas parte de tu tiempo que
siempre tiempo libre por cierto en ir a
colegios en institutos a contar lo que
haces a sembrar en esos chavales la
semilla de la curiosidad y que esa gente
con que uno de cada mil se dediquen a
investigar se dediquen a hacer a aportar
este conocimiento global tu impacto se
multiplica vale entonces en definitiva
en qué se basa la revolución que yo os
estoy demostrando hoy primero inversión
e inversión en ciencia básica en saber
cómo funciona el cerebro en saber qué
está pasando la interdisciplinaridad
esta palabra tan preciosa el factor
humano todo esto lo que va a generar es
la revolución una revolución en el
conocimiento sobre nuestro cerebro y es
que como dijo hace ya tiempo que al
sagan somos el medio para que el cosmos
se descubra a sí mismo hoy aquí en
manzanares a 14 de abril yo creo que
podemos afirmar que somos el medio para
que el cerebro se descubra a sí mismo
muchas gracias